it's a day we were all hoping for when
Coleman 19 first started to take a toll
back in March of 2020. since then
pharmacies were our go-to for free
testing and vaccines but now they could
cost you when the world first started to
get a glimpse of how fast covid-19 was
spreading Panic set in for the public
and health care workers so it's a very
scary and traumatic time to say the
least for healthcare workers more than
three years later covid-19 is no longer
considered a public health emergency
since the pandemic free testing and
getting vaccinated was encouraged and
sometimes even mandatory with the end of
the public health emergency Dr ashworia
Vayas Lahar is worried what that might
mean for the spread of covid it was
already a lot of challenges before when
it was free and covered and now that
it's not I feel like more people are
going to have more resistance if you
were to pay out of pocket we checked out
CVS and Walgreens a PCR coveted test
could cost you up to 129 dollars at home
tests start at ten dollars on Thursday
the Southern Nevada Health District held
a meeting wanting the public to know
free help will still be out there for a
bit longer it doesn't mean that uh that
is the against to the pandemic and also
that it doesn't mean the end of our
commit commitment to provide services
the health district says they will still
offer free vaccines at various locations
two College of Southern Nevada campuses
will also provide free testing and their
free coveted antigen tests and vending
machines at various Transit centers but
that will end March of 2024. Victoria
Saha 8 News Now
and you can check with your insurance to
see exactly what is covered in terms of
covid-19 testing or vaccines for those
who are uninsured the health district
says they will have programs to help out
families they also say it has been hard
to track coveted data because of the
rise of at-home testing they are now
using Hospital data to assess any
Community spread which of course has
been significantly down for months